[Music]
so straight back to los angeles outside
the courthouse which has been hearing
the britney spears case the free britney
case delight from some of her fans
outside u.s pop star britney spears
career has been in the hands of legal
guardians in an arrangement known as a
conservative ship since 2008 when she
faced a public mental health crisis the
court ordered agreement gave her father
control over her estate and large
aspects of her life to other aspects of
her life but no more let's bring in our
u.s correspondent greg marlon who joins
us live from outside the court in los
angeles and delight and emotion from the
fans greg tell us what's happened
yeah you could you could hear the cheer
from those fans outside the court inside
the court as the the judge in this case
made that ruling that jamie spears
should be suspended from his role as the
conservator uh in this arrangement now
the conservatorship itself will continue
with a uh a temporary conservator in
place until the court can work out how
to terminate it which is what britney
spears has requested but the removal of
her father is a significant moment in
the 13 years story of this
conservatorship and in particular the
last two years in this huge campaign
that has grown under the banner of free
britney the documentaries that have
emerged new ones even this week making
allegations about her treatment and of
course her own allegations that she made
to this court back in june or july of
what she said was an abusive
arrangement there was a lot of pretty
bad tempered argument in the court today
between the lawyers for jamie spears and
britney spears but in the in the end the
judge
brenda penny said this i do believe the
suspension of mr spears is in the best
interests of miss spears the current
situation is not tenable
and some changes need to be made an
accountant will become the the temporary
conservator of the uh of the estate
there will be more hearings in the weeks
to come to deal with that issue of
bringing the the whole conservatorship
uh to an end of course britney spears
and her lawyers want an investigation
into what's happened over the last uh 13
years so there are still some issues to
be sorted but the reaction from the fans
of britney spears and no doubt from
britney spears herself
will be will be clear tonight this is
what they wanted her father removed from
control of her affairs